ukrainian family with ties to a show on
the strip flees the country in order to
come here they left two sons behind to
fight the war and arrived here in las
vegas with just two suitcases eight news
now reporter jeremy j ford tells their
story and also lays out how you can help
this family in need
one of the strip's most popular shows
has left a footprint on the hearts of
the bobrovnik family
they used to live in las vegas because
he was a performer for cirque du soleil
and they lived here while contract was
on elena kilianova was also a performer
in the traveling show for five years
where the couple met and found love
before moving to ukraine in 2014
to be a family until the war started
at first
from kiev the bombing was far later it
started coming closer
and then the kids started getting scared
and the little one
every time she would hear siren she
would hide under the table but back here
in las vegas katya simoneko a local
business owner and esthetician reached
out to lend a hand since the war started
we started contacting them and we told
them right away we're going to help with
anything
if they can get here and within two
weeks they arrived with very little
belongings and two small children
looking to build a new life in our
they city in vegas before
and they left and they liked vegas
always and they left and they think that
it's really
you know a sign that they have to be
here because they're back to vegas to
start over with a dream to one day open
a school and teach acrobatics to young
children
they would like to have a studio here a
circus studio if they had money jeremy j
ford live local now and if you would
like to help the family you can send
donations to their go fund me page under
ukrainian family fleas to vegas from war